[Applause]
happy thursday everyone control yourself
before we get to the news let's continue
our halloween week with episode three
of our favorite sitcom
[Music]
tonight's episode a killer commute
[Music]
ah
and then they told me it was a 2246 in
progress and ah
would you look at this
i've seen it a million times
another miniature red plastic car
running over a co-worker after being
driven recklessly by a tiny grey gut
fell dummy
you know it never gets any easier
what the hell
what a waste of tape
the only way to silence emily campano
gotta run her over
so back to the news and as always when
it comes to the news
everything is racist
that's right everything is racist food
jokes vaccines pigeons that weird
feeling you get when you insert your
finger into your belly button
and then it turns out it's not your
belly button
or anyone
else's the only thing that's not racist
are actual racists
first let's talk docents do you know
what a docent is i had no idea until now
a docent however is now racist for it's
the term that describes volunteer guides
at museums they're usually older white
ladies who walk around telling you not
to touch the nude sculptures
like how was i supposed to know i mean
why go to the market if you can't
squeeze the fruit am i right tyrus
fruit fruit's not very big either some
of these docents are actual donors to
the museum and i bet they're typical
liberals just because you don't see many
dale earnhardt shirts at the museum of
national history but over at the art
institute of chicago more than a hundred
docents were fired because they were not
sufficiently diverse
although in chicago diversity means
getting the right mix of people who've
been shot and people who haven't
volunteers were fired because they were
too too white and that's got to hurt
being fired as a volunteer you can't
even collect unemployment
in your face white privilege
but i'm all for it i can't tell you how
many times i thought you know i need a
museum tour guide who looks just like me
i mean
i really feel marginalized where are
they
it's a struggle for me
so here's another example in which bozos
adopt the rhetoric of inclusion to
exclude others i mean these are
experienced people who donated time and
money to educate the public and they're
going to be hard to replace and why
let's be honest who does all the
volunteering i'll give you a hint you
won't find them at a jay-z concert or at
a nascar race no it's mostly
upper-middle-class white women named
melinda and dorothy who have who have
time on their hands since harry and leo
passed away years ago
picture janet yellen but with a woman's
haircut
men
men only volunteer when there's a gun to
their head probably because they held a
gun to someone's head
meaning it's community service
and i tell you picking up trash along a
highway is no way to spend five
saturdays
i never should have murdered that
weather man
but if you tell me to bring an umbrella
and it doesn't rain there is a price to
be paid
so diversity quotas end up harming those
it's supposed to help it's adopted the
rhetoric of equity in exchange for
competence it's about making yourself
feel better instead of making things
better it's like scratching a rash
instead of applying the ointment
god i hope it's just a rash as the wall
street journal writes civic institutions
have always relied on the volunteer work
of women with enough public spirit to
donate their time and money and we'll
miss them when they're gone so who's
gonna replace these women
cat
oh
her idea of volunteering is working at a
homeless shelter to find a better weed
connection
[Laughter]
weed if we're lucky
anyway docents are racist they're
probably white supremacists
just like larry elder and condoleezza
rice
according to the woe conservative blacks
are actually white supremacists yeah
black is really the new whites
which has to confuse the hell out of the
kkk
i guess we'll find out when joe biden
gets invited to their next funeral
shout out to robert byrd
but david duke must be pissed he spent
his life trying to be the face of white
racism and condoleezza comes along to
steal his thunder
so why are blacks stealing the jobs of
white bigots
maybe this could be progress i mean if
our white racists are so hard to find
that we must recruit colorblind black
leaders how awesome is that we killed
racism just by confusing it to death
i wonder what the angry black male
thinks
[Music]
what's up fellas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey jeans
we just heard the news we are so excited
you're going to be taking over for us we
got you everything you're gonna need in
this white guy starter kit white guy
starter kit yes sir oatmeal oatmeal
khakis
journeys greatest hits
and of course hockey tickets
this is for you enjoy the starter kit
whitey
[Music]
oh and can i borrow your street credit
card
[Music]
so while the woke media stokes division
black rapper bryson gray boots adele out
of the number one spot on itunes with
his banned anti-biden song and you hear
nothing about this because the left
can't deal with it it's a real cultural
shift but they don't like it one bit but
look a black guy beats a white woman
with a song about a terrible old white
president when will he be called a white
supremacist for that because over at the
fake news sports site deadspin they
called kyrie irving and dave chappelle
black pawns on a white chessboard and
why because they're black and share
similar thoughts as whites i know
individual thought transcending identity
groups it's crazy but deadspin believes
people of one color must think the same
which i think is racist fact is identity
politics is now segregating not just
people but ideas skills and talents
which always ends in bad ideas lack of
skill and zero talent i think that's the
new slogan for cnn
but if you go to a museum you got to
ignore a white docent even if they're
good at it if you're condoleezza rice
you best hold an opinion that other
blacks have especially famous black
intellectuals like joy behar
of course thinking for yourself like
irving isn't really thinking for
yourself if some d-bag at dead spin
thinks you sound white and the same goes
for chappelle sure he was ripping on
whites and that was fine but once he
made fun of trans he's now white himself
i tell you you need a score card to keep
up with who's racist and who isn't maybe
it's best to say that everything is
racist finally something we can all take
part in
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he's the perfect bloke to provoke the
woke columbia university professor and
author of the brand new book woke racism
john mcwhorter
he can drop more beats than a clumsy
farmer
rapper producer r.a the rugged man
she puts razor blades in her own
halloween candy boxes contributor cat
tim
[Applause]
and he's so tough he goes bobbing for
pineapples my massive sidekick and the
nwa world television champion iris
john welcome to the show thank you greg
nice to meet you it's good to meet you
too you got good timing for this book
huh woke racism i kind of did yes
there's an awful lot of it out there
lately i know where does this fit this
whole idea of docents it's it's really
very interesting how many people have
ever gone to that museum and saw those
women and thought that i wished i were
one of them i really don't understand
that
nevertheless we have this problem the
idea is you have to battle white power
right white people have all the power
you've got to battle that if you're not
battling that then you're not going to
get into heaven and therefore you have
to get rid of the white docents
condoleezza rice is a white supremacist
all of it makes a certain kind of sense
if you understand that there's this
church of battling white supremacy and
that being the only thing you do other
than maybe taking some lessons on the
recorder now and then maybe doing some
water coloring a little bit else but
mainly what you do is you're fighting
the white man that's the religion and
that's actually kind of what my book is
about but that's what all those stories
have in common right exactly they just
there's a new one every week r.a welcome
back haven't seen you in years yeah i
moved to another country yeah berlin
they tried to blame it when because i
moved around when trump and hillary you
know was going at each other and it was
oh he left the country because of trump
and hillary you know i had kids out
there so i left
with my children i wasn't afraid of
trump and hillary so you followed a
woman
yeah a nice school teacher out there
[Laughter]
what do you make of this uh this this
trend well the whole thing especially
with dave chappelle that's what i see
the most is and what happens is they
that you get like dead spin yeah you
know a racist white you know
organization you know owned by racist
white people and then they go well he
doesn't have our opinion so let's get a
black writer to write the column yes so
they won't see our racism and then
he's speaking for us and see this is how
the black community feels no that's one
black writer yeah and if you really look
at you know uh the majority of black
community they all have dave chappelle's
back you know like you look at every
every uh
the real people not just twitter people
you know right dave chappelle's my man
he's a genius he's a legend he's one of
the greats he's the goat you know so
they're not uh they're not too offended
by dave chappelle you know and most of
them you know most of the world grew up
on comedy this new new you know you know
red fox you know oh god lenny bruce and
all of that stuff so now it's time to uh
oh they've they've offended us now so
not offended by that now tyrus excellent
angry black male 2 oh thank you
welcome to the welcome to the club yeah
um do you want my i have monogram towels
i lost my membership card
i lost it i
please take me back it's scary i don't i
don't like mayonnaise and oatmeal
[Laughter]
you know you know they make great points
the best thing about chappelle
is that he's in his position when you
have fu money yeah you don't have to
play the game right and he's not playing
the game because if they were successful
and they i guess they kind of got a
small victory because they got his his
documentary no one wants to produce it
or whatever but then he just instead of
doing and think man i'm glad that he
didn't do the apology right the two-page
twitter apology yeah because then that's
when they take the ginsu off and cut
your head off yeah so i'm glad he's
standing his ground but more people are
starting to
turn and look like enough of this like
we've had enough of this and the other
thing
it's not has nothing to do with racism
it has to do with the thirst to get
where someone else is at because
they all we've seen so many people
coming out that want to talk to dave
right so many people want to lecture
them here's the deal let's do this he'll
meet with you but there's no cameras no
media you can't profit from it you meet
in a dark room you shake hands you can't
talk about it how many of them would
actually show up for that because that's
not what it's really about yeah that's
true yeah they want to act and also if
you go after a big star and you're just
some like weird twitter freak
it raises your persona and not only that
but here's the deal if you get
which is ironic you want to build your
platform off the back of another of a
black man we've seen that before yeah
okay
you talk with chappelle then you're
going to go on the view then you're
going to know they're going to get a
reality tv show on we and ion so of
course you're outraged
because this could be a lot of dollars
for you yeah so he needs to hurry up and
meet with us because i've already spent
money on production so that's really
what this is about
you know kat you're really the expert
here on race right yes
i think you'd make an excellent docent
you already have the black dress and the
glasses no and you're a wh and you're a
white woman when i'm older well it
depends if i have kids or not if i have
kids i'll be going to the bar with my
kids oh that's sweet
if i don't i'll be drinking mouthwash
with the men i meet in the nursing homes
that's so romantic at least i have a
plan yes um
no but it's it's not just race either i
mean this week also uh nbc had a column
come out saying is kirsten cinema bad
for bisexual people yes
because she's not far left right you
know which is worse for bisexual people
saying that if you are attracted to men
and women you have to think this certain
way or you'll be publicly smeared
or
you know kirsten cinema thinking for
herself despite who she's attracted to
i'm not about gatekeeping what people
are allowed to believe based on you know
gender race or sexuality and apparently
that's a right-wing thing i don't
understand yeah what's happening is okay
so we saw this this uh this separation
of identity in race as the as the first
part of this but what they really want
now is the separation of ideas and
talents which is a disaster because
the point of a melting pot is that we
share everything
at least with people who have other
talents one day you'll meet them
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else